ok you're les paras potes on est dans
une vision un peu spécial j'ai pas le
times j'ai pas le tas et milliers dé son
propre responsable responsable je vais
nettoyer mes lunettes
j'ai pas le times vous voyez j'ai c'est
de sortir une vidéo par semaine enfin je
sens au bio par semaine en fait depuis
j'ai fait une mini pause vite en janvier
et je me tiens quoi et en fait c'est
important pour moi c'est devenu un
challenge important
ben alors il ya aussi le fait que la
chaîne j'attends que ça ça prend
vraiment que ça un impact quoi mais même
moi à titre personnel c'est un challenge
et parfois comme cette semaine c'est
chaud de ouf parce que j'ai plein de
trucs à faire j'ai pris de retard sur
des trucs j'avais mini avance gelé
reperdu je me suis permis un week-end de
partir dans le sud de la france le mec
il n'a pas travaillé au caire donc
d'avis tu seras et tous les week-ends et
donc là avec tout ça bref j'ai galéré
j'ai galéré et donc là cette semaine
j'avais pas de vidéo que j'ai pas tant
je vous ai dit j'ai pas thème je mange
même toit plein de choses partout qu'est
ce que j'aurais pu voilà j'aurais pu
j'aurais pu me laisser abattre et je me
suis dit est ce qu elle pas un truc que
tu peux faire qui est simple quoi songer
déjà les trade les fred qui me qui est
en gros c'est que du temps de montage
il ya du temps de tournage mais je dire
y'a pas d'écriture ça j'aimerais bien ne
pas en faire plus d'un par mois donc
j'ai réfléchi et je me suis rappelé de
la vidéo qu'on a fait avec un mix enjoy
cas c'est une vidéo sans filet où on
parle pendant 40 minutes et
une grosse partie de la conversation
c'est moi qui l'a fait en balançant des
trucs philosophique quoi et je me suis
dit est ce qu a pas un petit truc à
trouver là dedans
et là j'ai une idée je prône une lettre
donc la raconter par la lettre a et je
vais donner une dizaine de mots qui
commence par cette lettre et je vous en
parlais de ces mots là je vous
expliquais des trucs ou des anecdotes
tout ce genre de choses
alors ceux qui tombent de leur chaise en
disant le mec se foule pas vous avez
écouté le reste de pourquoi je reviens
faire ça on pourrait dire cyrus t'es pas
obligé de faire une vidéo par semaine et
concentre toi et fais lui que des trucs
hyper qualitatif faisant moins mais que
du lit plat qualitatif mayette et phase
où j'ai envie de faire ça il ya des
phases où j'ai pas envie de faire ça là
je suis dans une phase où j'ai pas envie
de faire ça flashe sont dans une phase
où vraiment ce truc de une vidéo par
semaine je vous ai dit c'est devenu un
challenge c'est devenu un truc qui me
qui me meut le cas quand j'arrêterai et
je prendrai plus de temps pour faire des
vidéos hyper léchée machin guetta mais
là j'aime bien en fait j'aime bien
descoings s'est aussi un peu ma chaîne
youtube et faire ce que je veux en fait
cher que des fois il ya des vidéos qui
sont léchés et c où je creuse des trucs
et des fois tu m'en bats les steaks
alors c'est vrai j'ai été mes premières
vidéos c'était des vidéos de philo un
peu plus poussée etc
c'était à 7 ans je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui m'ont découvert
avec ça qu'ils sont partis alors il y en
a beaucoup qui sont encore là et vous le
dirai dans les commentaires j'en suis
sûr mais c'est des gens qui ont grandi
qui s'il avait besoin de creuser
certains sujets ils l'ont fait par eux
mêmes ils n'ont pas attendu
j'espère en tout cas moi je prends mon
envol je prends ma liberté et donc en
fait vu qu'il ya 26 lettres dans
l'alphabet bah ça c'est un joker et je
pourrais utiliser ce joker 26 fois voilà
peut-être que je vais faire que trois
lettres cette aiguille 6 ouais j'ai dit
en anglais parce que les klaxons fight
non mais bon plus sérieusement voilà
peut-être que je vais arrêter en plein
milieu peut-être que vous allez qui
vidéo vous allez venir
hazim effect toutes les lèvres en fait
ne fait que ça il ya peut-être un moment
je vais devoir inventer un nouvel
alphabet puisqu'au bout de 26 vidéo je
serai bloqué voilà c'est un assez gros
disclaimer jours heureux sont commence
tout de suite par la lettre a et le
premier mot je vais faire tout ce qui
est en train de manger en fait donc je
trouve que pour l'intro ça allait acte
manqué il ya un concept qui commence par
a et que j'aime bien qui s'appelle actes
manqués un mec te manquer c'est un
concept freudien à la base c'est une
action qu'on va faire mais qui traduit
des pulsions qui sont inavoués qui sont
inavouables
ça se passe au niveau de l'inconscient
je vous donne un exemple j'ai grave
envie de m'acheter un nouveau téléphone
mais je sais que c'est pas sérieux je
sais que c'est pas de gamme le fer etc
mais c'est au niveau un peu inconscient
voyez genre je sais pas si j'ai pris
conscience que j'avais envie de
m'acheter un nouveau téléphone et ben du
coup
georges me faire voler mon téléphone
évidemment je n'ai pas planifié le vol
mais je faire moins attention je le
mettre sur le côté un moment où il
pourrait se faire voler etc tout ça de
manière inconsciente et je me le faire
voler ou alors je vais le casser ça que
à mon jeu pendant un risque et le faire
tomber
et en fait parce qu'il parle moi je dis
vous allez au pire y tombe c'est quoi le
pire c'est que tu dois m'en racheter un
ce serait vraiment dommage non je suis
sûr que ça vous dire un truc c à vous
est déjà arrivé ou quoi eh ben ça
s'appelle un acte manqué toi qui est
aussi une chanson les actes manqués
ml on change de mon très vite très vite
absolue il ya un mot qui est hyper
important a aussi en philosophie en
réflexion de manière générale c'est
l'absolue barça s'opposa relatifs et
c'est quelque chose qui pour n'existait
ne dépend que d'eux soit 1 ya une forme
d'indépendance d'autosuffisance
peut-être content des travaux il ya des
travaux je sais pas si c'est gênant pas
j'espère pas la grande question c'est
est ce qu'il ya une vérité absolue et a
priori non mais donc si je dis non il
n'y a pas de vérité absolue
est-ce que ça ça se présente pas comme
une vérité absolue ah là là on rentre
dans un paradoxe les paras potes
un paradoxe ce sera pas le premier et ce
sera pas le dernier de cette série
peut-être l'egypte fait que ce sera le
premier peut-être qu'il n'aurait qu'un
seul dans cette vidéo et qu'il y aura
qu'une seule vidéo de ça parce que
j'aurais plus jamais besoin de joker
carrément et d'ailleurs il ya une
citation ans on a bien une station qui
va avec incitation de jules l'agneau
qu'ils étaient bouchés ou végétariens
s'arrêter le contre-pied il n'y a qu'une
vérité absolue c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
vérité absolue alors la présence y ont
renoncé à l'absolu ce n'est ni renoncer
à l'objectivité ni à l'universalité
on peut être tous d'accord sur une
vérité mais ce n'est pas une vérité
absolue gens là il fait beau tous ceux
qui sont avec moi il y en a pas mais
imaginons on était plein tout on est
d'accord voudrait qu'il fait beau mais
ça reste que levet qui fasse beau c'est
pas une vérité absolue
agnosticisme petit mot agnosticisme donc
c'est souvent on retrouve en contexte de
la religion en fait on dit à quelqu'un
ouais tu crois en dieu ou quoi et la
personne va nous répondre peut-être je
suis agnostique
qu'est ce que ça veut dire exactement ça
veut dire que je ne me prononce pas sur
l'existence ou non de dieu mais je
trouve ça intéressant de rappeler qu'en
fait c'est un terme qui marchent pas que
dans le domaine de la religion
l'agnosticisme c'est le refus de se
prononcer sur des principes absolus
il est 4 heures du matin je j'ai à peu
près de finir mon live parce que je live
tous les mardis soirs je sais pas ce qui
s'est passé j'ai perdu le contrôle sur
ce live
d'habitude ça dure deux heures à saturer
5 donc les 4 heures du matin mardi soir
ou mercredi matin
donc cette vidéo sort dans 14 heures
j'ai pas dîner est-ce que c'est absurde
de manger des chips à 4h du mat
absurde l'absurde c'est vraiment l'un
mes raisonnements préférée notamment en
maths pour prouver quelque chose
enfin raisonnement par l'absurde je
faisais toujours classe quoi l'idée
c'est de prendre la contradiction de ce
qu'on veut montrer cette contradiction
on va montrer qu'elle aboutit à quelque
chose qui n'a aucun sens et donc c'est à
dire que ce qu'on voulait prouver est
vrai après c'est aussi une forme
d'humour que j'aime bien
à mme lam lam c'est le souffle de la vie
quoi le plus souvent cela est conçu
comme immatériel séparables du corps et
donc éternelle et d'ailleurs cette
séparation entre l'âme et le corps ça
s'appelle le dualisme aujourd'hui l'âme
c'est une notion qui est de plus en plus
discuté parce qu on est de plus en plus
en fait matérialiste alors en
philosophie aide matérialiste c'est pas
du tout juger les gens par rapport à
quel iphone izon ça n'a rien à voir avec
ça en fait la doctrine matérialiste
c'est de considérer que tout est composé
de matières d'abord et que tout
phénomène et résultat d'interactions de
matière donc forcément vu qu' on est de
plus en plus matérialiste et que l'âme
a priori c'est pas de la matière c'est
quelque chose qui est genre spirituel et
ben on a de plus en plus de mal à
considérer l'âme moi une question que je
me posais de temps en temps avec un pote
qui s'appelle alexis je sais pas si tu
regarde cette vidéo mon ami c'est quand
j'étais en échange le canada pendant
cinq mois donc c'est des road trip et où
tous les deux et donc on a beaucoup
discuté en voiture et la question de la
mpt revenait souvent dans nos
discussions et on avait une expérience
de pensée qu'on trouve intéressante
en gros si parce que vous allez on peut
imprimer en 3d du vivant parce que il me
semble que la nasa quoi imprimer des
arbres en 3d enfin bref je sais plus
exactement l'anecdote mais on peut
imprimer du vivant en 3d avec des
cellules en fait on imprime des cellules
et donc on s'est dit imaginons donc dans
des décennies voire des siècles qu'on
est la technologie assez poussées
pourquoi faire un scan 3d très précis de
notre corps est ensuite l'imprimer en 3d
imprimé en 3d un clone de nous-mêmes et
bien est ce que cette version 3 d
imprimer est-ce que corps il sera en vie
ou est ce que ce sera une version genre
inerte voilà en tout cas que cette
question était hyper intéressante et
elle nous a tenus de longues heures
éveillé
âme soeur l'autre mot lié à ça c'est
l'âme soeur évidemment dans le banquet
platon il nous parle d'un mythe
en fait les humains à la base il était
né avec genre quatre jambes quatre bras
et de tête
ça ressemblait à ça un peu flippant
tellement flippant que même deux s'il en
a eu peur il a eu peur de leur pouvoir
et du coup ils les aident divise en deux
et en fait l'âme soeur c'est cet autre
partie de son corps qu'on passe sa vie à
essayer de retrouver
selon ce mythe de platon dans le
bancaire
a priori c'est faux c'est un mythe
aristote celui qui a écrit un truc
fondateur sur l'âme c'est aristote et
écrit un livre qui s'appelle de l'âme
pour lui il y avait trois types dame y
avait l'âme végétative ou sensitive
c'était l'âme des plantes des végétaux
la motrice c'est l'âme des animaux et
l'âme intellectuelle c'est l'âme des
êtres humains et c'est intéressant parce
que l'âme d'un point de vue religieux
c'est souvent seulement les humains
souvent je pas faire de généralités
alors que la aristote il avait vraiment
pris tous les êtres vivants en compte et
a pas mal d anecdotes intéressantes sur
aristote
c'est un élève de platon c'était le
précepteur de alexandre le grand
c'est celui qui a fondé le lycée et
c'est le créateur de la métaphysique et
c'est assez marrant d'où il vient ce
nombre métaphysique en fait quand on a
récupéré ses écrits et qu'on a voulu les
classes et après sa mort il y avait donc
la physique et un bouquin qui était
juste après la physique on a mis tous
ces éléments là est donc un grec s'était
genre mme état physique
donc après la physique mais sauf que un
autre sens de métaphysique
c'est au delà de la physique et donc le
terme métaphysique
même si ce n'était pas pour ça à la base
était hyper approprié une autre anecdote
c'est qu'il disait le monde en deux
catégories ceux qui avaient un pistolet
chargé et ceux qui creusent pas du tout
il dit viser le monde en deux catégories
la catégorie supra lunaire c'est ce qui
était en fait au delà de la lune et la
catégorie sublunaire tout ce qui était
supra lunaire pour aristote on pouvait
pas savoir si ça pouvait subir les lois
de la détérioration du temps par exemple
les choses se détériorent à cause du
temps supra lunaire on pouvait pas
savoir
par contre ce qui était sublunaire c'est
sûr que c'était soumis à cette règle
en fait c'est intéressant ce que les
chrétiens repris cette séparation ils
ont juste appeler le sublunaire la terre
et le supra lunaire le ciel est donc
c'est dans le supra lunaire qui peut y
avoir à l'éternel par exemple alors que
la terre bomba sur terre c'est compliqué
c'est vrai il ya une vraie
hiérarchisation entre la terre et le
ciel
aristocratie à ce moment que le terme
aristocratie il n'a rien à voir avec
aristote aristo ce ça vient de le
meilleur et kratos c'est le pouvoir
en fait l'aristocratie c'est le pouvoir
aux meilleurs donc c'est un régime ou en
fait ceux qui gouvernent sont les
meilleurs donc les plus compétents on
est plus honnête et sait il peut y avoir
plusieurs critères qui fait qu'on est le
meilleur est derrière pour aristote les
élections c'était une forme
d'aristocratie surtout par rapport à ce
qui se faisait en grèce à l'époque qui
était le tirage au sort parce que
forcément on élisait les meilleurs ou en
tout cas selon certains critères les
meilleures jambes sont que c'est assez
méconnu sa jambe sont pour beaucoup de
gens l'aristocratie c'est le pouvoir aux
riches
voilà ce qui fait que quand donc
certaines discussions je disais que je
serai que l'aristocratie s'était changé
et que ça avait du sens parfois il ya
quelques quiproquos
ascétisme l'ascétisme c'est une doctrine
morale qui prône le dénuement la
pauvreté le renoncement est vraiment
cette notion d'effort de laisser tomber
plein de choses de se priver de plein de
choses pour aboutir à quelque chose de
supérieur parfois on a une image et
c'est pour ça que je vous en parle et on
a une image des stoïciens comme dû
penser à ses tics et ses faux en fait la
baule stoïcisme ne dis pas que le
dénuement où la pauvreté c'est bien il
ne l'associent pas aux biens et enfin
dans ses écrits sénèque excuses
clairement que le fait qu'il soit riche
n'est pas un obstacle au fait qu'ils
soient stoïciens n'est pas un obstacle à
sa sagesse et qu'au contraire en fait le
fait de pas voir des problématiques
liées à l'argent savaient qu'ils
pouvaient se soucier d'autre chose et
réfléchir à d'autres besoins qu'ils
avaient et donc travailler sur sa
sagesse et d'ailleurs nietzsche condamne
fortement l'ascétisme il dit que c'est
une morale pour les faibles parce que il
ya une mutilation de l'existence il ya
un sacrifice
voilà ataraxie et appâter ya alors un
parent à kci et à pattaya l'ataraxie
c'est l'absence de troubles et la
bataille assez l'absence de passion donc
c'est des choses qui sont visés par les
épisodes et les stoïciens souvent
l'ataraxie s'est associé aux épicuriens
et la pâtée ya au stoïcien mais en fait
la patte eia c'est plus c'est pas juste
toutes les passions c'est surtout les
mauvaises passions et c'est vraiment ce
processus de s'éloigner des mauvaises
passions pour soient rapprochés des
bonnes passion et donc on peut dire que
le stoïcien passe par la pâtée ya pour
atteindre l'ataraxie
et donc ça ça se fait par un effort sur
soi mais c'est pas de la cèze pour
autant d'ailleurs pour l'anecdote
siddharta gautama donc le bouddha avant
de trouver cette ce qu'il a appelé la
troisième voie c'est à dire une voix
s'est modérée finalement dans sa manière
de pratiquer il est passé par une phase
totalement ascétique genre avec de la
privation prévention notamment de
nourriture etc
on a l'habitude de voir le boudin
représenté comme ça et ben en fait le
bouddha a aussi connu une phase où l'it
est comme ça voilà bah c'est ça
ascétique j'espère que cette vidéo très
différentes
vous a plu c'est un joker ça ce soir je
vais pas aller jusqu'à la lettre z en
fait mais bon ça me laisse du temps
voilà ça me laisse du temps pour
préparer la vidéo de la semaine
prochaine finir les choses que j'avais à
faire et puis c'est intéressant je vous
c'est intéressant quand même de garder
ce truc demi d'eau par semaine parce que
vous voyez c'est dans la contrainte que
j'ai eu cette idée de vidéos et ça se
trouve à vous plaire de ouf ça se trouve
pas du tout ça se trouve je n'ai pas du
tout aimé mais ça ce sera à vous plaire
je sais pas du tout comment je vais
appeler cette vidéo voilà il est 5h du
mat passé et je suis en train d'hydrater
ma peau c'est n'importe quoi
j'avais toujours rêvé de faire une
routine mais quelle par exemple bon pas
vraiment mec parce que je n'ai pas de
maquillage mais une routine soins en
parant philosophie c'est bon je l' ai
longtemps imaginé ça c'est toujours un
format qui m'a fait un peut délirer et
je pensais pas le faire comme ça voilà
parce que vraiment ça ressemble à ça là
ok j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura
plu on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour une vidéo plus classiques d'ici là
portez vous bien l'homme
pis ciao